John, you have spent a lot of time with Kit Harington.
I think he's the only cast member I have not personally met.
Is he as good looking in person
as he appears on television.
(audience whooping)
Oh God, this guy--
What?
This guy, I mean,
(laughing)
seeing him on screen is nice enough, right?
[Conan] Yeah.
It's nothing compared to what
I'm gonna call the live experience.
(audience laughs)
It's nothing like it.
It's a bit like only every seeing
the Mona Lisa as a jpeg on somebody's phone.
(laughing)
Somebody says, "What do you think of that?"
You go, "Yeah, it's a pretty good painting.
"I'm not blown away by it."
But you see it in real life, and you're like, "Good Lord."
[Conan] Yeah. (laughs)
(audience cheers)
But the thing about him that's so frustrating
is he's a man of absolutely no compromise either.
There's a selfie of us that I put on my Instagram
where we're both kinda leanin' in,
and I'm doing puppy dog,
because it's kind of all I've got, right?
So, I'm doing puppy dog like this.
(audience cheers)
Oh ho.
Gonna do more puppy dog.
And then I say, "Right, cheers mate, thanks for that."
And I look at it, and he's doing puppy dog as well.
I'm like don't do puppy dog as well.
I wouldn't do puppy dog if I had those abs.
(laughing)
Stay away from my schtick.
You can't have abs and puppy dog.
You've gotta make a choice,
otherwise it just looks like greed.
Yeah, he got a double dose at the factory, yeah.
He's got a double dose of all the good stuff.
He's right in the sweet spot between good lookin',
vulnerable, smart, talented.
[Conan] Yeah, you seem bitter about this.
No, no, no, no.
(laughing)
I just wish he'd leave me with one thing.